Okay. My disclosures. So is Hodgkin a heterogeneous disease? So the obvious answer is yes, everything
is heterogeneous. If you look into the WHO classification currently, Hodgkin lymphoma
is mainly divided by the appearance of the tumor microenvironment. That's just the biology
of the disease, that there is a very heterogeneous mix of cells with the malignant cells in the
minority. And these ecosystems are still very poorly understood, both the malignant cell
genomics and then corresponding tumor microenvironment inflammatory reactions. So really an integrative
approach is needed to come up with something better that is clinically relevant. So if
you look into these four subtypes, nodular sclerosis, neuroendocrine, neuromuscular disease,
mixed cilillarity, lymphocyte depleted, lymphocyte rich, so all of these don't really have a
bearing on clinical decision making. And then the nodular lymphocyte predominant that you
see on the far right here, so that's likely to lose the age and the Hodgkin might be dropped
in future classifications. So we need to come up with something biologically informed and
just also to polarize a little bit here. And I know that my co-speakers will expand on that,
but just to polarize, there's regional differences in how people think about how to treat and
there's two breakthrough studies that are, I'm sure, cited often in the next talks as
well. New England Journal 2024, the volume of AVD being superior to BV AVD and then the
more European interpretation, they are holding on to brentuximab and treatment intensification.
So there's different thoughts, and the thoughts are mostly biologically uninformed, I would say.
And so we tackled the problem by starting from the ground up with an integrative genomic study design,
basically doing everything we can at the moment with modern technologies, single cell, spatial
transcriptomics, TME characterizations by imaging mass cytometry, have Hodgkin-Reed-Sternberg cells
microdissected, and then we can do a lot of other things, and then we can do a lot of other things
as well. We can do a lot of other things, and then we can do a lot of other things, and then we can do a lot of other things
that flow-sorted, and then for the same samples put onto tissue microarrays so that we can read
out on the tumor microenvironment, and then outcome correlates and modeling as well.
So this is the essence of the study that is now published in Cancer Discovery just a couple of
weeks ago, where we discovered, based on NMF clustering on the mutational profiles, we just
have four types that we labeled CST-CN91.
3 STB and CN2P, so these are code names for actually the mutations that are found in these
clusters, either copy number or simple mutations. And you can see on the right-hand side here that
there's correlates to age and EBV, which there's hints in the literature, of course, that there is
relevance to EBV positivity versus negative disease, and also
individual mutations have been described before that are more enriched in pediatric or adolescent
young adult lymphoma versus elderly Hodgkin lymphoma, so I don't want to linger too much
on that. So this tool to distinguish now four Hodgkin lymphoma types is available as a tool
publicly downloadable. We call it HLGEN, which has an unclassifiable group, and then the four
types that I just referenced to you. And the good thing about this tool is that it's not just
a single-use tool, it can be used to do a lot of other things. So the good news is this pretty much
aligns with an earlier publication by Ash Elizadeh, who is in the conference, I don't see him here,
but wonderful collaboration with Stefan Alig and Ash to actually show that this classification
system also works on CT DNA, and future studies will hopefully validate these classes.
So now moving on to a tumor microenvironment vignette in the very limited time.
So, again, we did not only the mutational classification, we also interrogated simultaneously
the tumor microenvironment by imaging mass cytometry, 35 protein markers, and we just looked
into spatial vicinity to the Hodgkin-Rietz-Durnberg cells. So I think in Hodgkin, it's quite intuitive
to ask the specific question, what is an immediate contact to the malignant cells or in an interaction
radius of the malignant cells, and what is an immediate contact to the malignant cells, or in an
interaction radius of the malignant cells, and what is an immediate contact to the malignant cells,
and you see here a very concrete example that I will now show you. CSF2RB mutations in,
that's the C in the CST, and a correlate to FOXP3-positive, CD4-positive cells,
and then also a correlation to CCL17-positive, positivity on HRS cells, and as you know,
CCL17 and CCR4, and that's a correlation to CCL17-positive, positivity on HRS cells,
on regulatory T cells is an obvious link here. So, but before I go there, CSF2RB mutations are
actually the most common truncating mutations that we see in mediastinal lymphomas, and that's not
only Hodgkin's, this is also primary mediastinal, or Spiezel lymphoma, and mediastinal gray zone
lymphoma. So there's something specific to the thymic mediastinal niche that selects for,
in particular, these mutations, which are in the,
um,
common beta chain. So CSF2RB is the common beta chain to the IL-3 receptor alpha, IL-4 receptor
alpha, and CSF2RA alpha receptors that, um, um, build these, um, these complexes and then signal,
signal-bound stream, um, through, for example, JAK stats, um, and PI3 kinase, um, pathways.
So here, the mutational profile, as you see, um, it's a hotspot mutation that is specifically found
in, in, in Hodgkin's disease, but there's other, um,
N-terminal, excuse me, C-terminal mutations that we have characterized. So here is one of the
functional readouts. So to make a long story short, if we express these various mutants in
Hodgkin models, we see an upregulation of CCL17 or TARC and IL13. And that this has a very nice
correlate also then in the tumor microenvironment composition. So HRS cells that are high in TARC
in CCL17, you see that there is a spatial contact with CCR4 positive T cells. And you see some
representative false color images on the right. So we just see actually quite some diversity in
these tumor microenvironments, some cases where the tumor microenvironments are packed with CCR4
positive T cells when TARC is expressed by Hodgkin-Reed's term.
So here's the model, for example, in the CST genomic subgroup now. So signaling through JAK-STAT,
it's jumped here ahead, STAT5 signaling, upregulation of CCL17 and IL13, and this
recruits a very specific tumor microenvironment. So there is linkage between Hodgkin-Reed-Sternberg
cell genetics and TME architecture. So we can read out the mutational profiles through a new tool,
HLGEN, and we can...
easily discuss how now this might be a framework for targeted therapies, for example, JAK-STAT
signaling or CCR4 interference. And yeah, happy to discuss that if desired. And finally, I want to
thank my colleagues at the Center for Lymphoid Cancer. Tomohiro Aoki has moved on to Princess
Margaret Cancer Center. Big thanks to him for driving the study. But yeah, my clinical colleagues
and Ash Elizabeth Day and Stanford Medicine for the awesome collaboration. Thank you very much.